quel est pour toi le comble de la misère
le comble de la misère
je pense que surtout que la misère est
un comble ton idéal de bonheur terrestre
ce serait d'avoir tous les malheurs
qu'on enfile sur la tronche toute la
journée je crois que les bonnes heures
on sait fabrique soit artificiellement
ou moralement ou physiquement vous mais
le mien je crois qu'il est plutôt dans
la fumée dans le havane qui me consume
plutôt que lui quoi pour quelle faute
aurais-tu de plus d'indulgence pour la
plaisanterie hélas ce souvent ma
concierge a dit que la plaisanterie
avait des limites mais c'est de
l'intolérance
là ça va être facile ton peintre favori
c'est sûrement pas van gogh vendu clair
vingt deux favoris c'est un portugais va
qui habite en face de chez moi qui pas
exactement ce que je lui demande ce qui
est assez rare parce que souvent ils
vous proposent autre chose le papier par
un serait mieux pour le dessus et il a
peint en noir donc chez moi dans tout à
fait convaincu passion préférée
lannoy notre patient plus tôt enfin
c'est une préférence à condition d'avoir
fait quelque chose avant bien entendu
des foules bien pour avoir le mal et le
mal par le bien
non tu aurais aimé être qu'ici tu
n'étais pas jacques mutez et du rhin sa
part toi je vois pas grand monde
tellement est-ce que tu apprécies le
plus chez tes amis leurs variétés en
tout cas ce que moi ils vont de d'un
bouquiniste accordéoniste un prof de
maths c'est pas un boucher un pompier
enfin pour se dire une espèce de panel
intéressant
je ne suis pas fixé sur des amis comme
on pourrait dire professionnelle entre
ligne le don de la nature que tu
voudrais avoir je ne sais pas un don de
la nature c'est le doigt vers le pouce
vert comme on dit là que verte aussi
parce que
j'ai été marié qu'une belle plante et
pour en finir je sais comment il aurait
pu mourir mourir guéri comme dirait
c'est acquis parce que je veux dire
souffrir pour vivre c'est bien mais
souffrir pour mourir c'est un peu chiant
comme une teigne de vie joue pas non
plus oui nous paraît bon genre habitants
de los angeles sens le vent je suis le
meilleur et je vais rester le meilleur
jusqu'à demain et devin je verrai non
pas d'une pâte devises
je veux pas être le premier de la classe
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu